If you’re in a relationship and you don't know what to say to your partner
when they're feeling down or sad
they seem inconsolable
saying these simple phrases will
always have a big impact on your relationship
not only that
it'll make them fall in love with you over and over again
People who say these phrases
in relationships are generally happier and
their love is generally stronger
It’s so important to make your partner feel
understood and emotionally secure
so say these phrases, whenever you don't know what to say
No. one “what do you need for me, I'm here”
if you say that to your partner
they will be shocked
A, because no one ever says that
and B, makes them feel secure(emotionally validated)
Also saying, “your thoughts matter to me, tell me more”
communication is obviously key to any healthy relationship
Oops I set it to one minute,
so I'll do a part two.